[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to be
discussing just exactly how harry came
back from the dead in the final
installment of the series i'm of course
referring to how harry was able to
return to the world of the living after
voldemort hits him with his evada
kadavra or killing curse in harry potter
and the deathly hallows so what do we
know well we know that harry dies or at
least we think he does setting the scene
we are in the forbidden forest as harry
comes face to face with voldemort after
years of encounters with he who shall
not be named but unlike previous
confrontations from his meeting with a
fragmented voldemort attached to
professor quirrell to their jewel in the
graveyard of little angleton this time
harry does not intend to defend himself
or fight back he's come to die fans of
the book will remember the chapter as
the aptly named the forest again and
movie lovers will certainly know this
scene as the one right after harry sees
his dead loved ones through the magic of
the resurrection stone one of the three
fabled deathly hallows voldemort and his
followers are waiting for harry to turn
himself over a deal voldemort has
proposed in exchange for the safety of
the other wizards who've been fighting
alongside harry in the battle of
hogwarts initially harry approaches the
group under the cover of his
invisibility cloak taking in the scene
he overhears that voldemort thinks he
hasn't come i was it seems mistaken said
voldemort to which harry reveals himself
with a simple you weren't from there
things move rather quickly harry having
discovered that he must die in order to
defeat voldemort doesn't even draw his
wand as voldemort curses him dead he saw
the mouth move and a flash of green
light and everything was gone so what
exactly happens next i suppose you could
argue that maybe voldemort never
actually utters the killing curse the
words avada kadavra don't actually
appear on the page however as one of the
three unforgivable curses we know that
it projects a bright green light when
it's cast so there's one for the killing
curse also in the movie we most
definitely hear voldemort after the
words avada kadavra and so one might
assume that harry has instantly died as
everyone does when hit with the curse
with the exception of infant harry who
survived due to his mother lily
sacrificing her life for his so if
harry's died what comes next perhaps now
we move on to one of the other main
characters perspectives but this is
harry potter so that can't be right well
then maybe we get a glimpse into where
harry goes in death in that assumption
you would be correct well almost we're
taken to a kind of limbo a strange
in-between reality harry is not alive
but he's also not dead how do we know
that it's purgatory and not just some
place of magic we're actually provided
with many a clue initially harry simply
lies in a blanket of bright mist not
like mist he had ever experienced before
until his conscious awakens to the fact
that he still exists as he slowly begins
to discover his surroundings the mist
begins to clear and he realizes that
he's naked hmm bit weird but okay then
clothes magically appear as he needs or
rather as he wants them later his
location reveals itself inexplicably to
be king's cross railway station harry
also discovers a grotesque being
struggling to survive nearby of course
all this could be chalked up to magic
after all this is the wizarding world of
harry potter but then dumbledore we all
know to be dead approaches him we now
understand he's in a place where he can
interact with the dead without the magic
of a resurrection stone it would be
reasonable at this point to conclude
that harry himself is dead that he has
come to a sort of afterlife in fact
that's the conclusion that harry comes
to as well having the following exchange
with his old headmaster but you're dead
said harry oh yes sir dumbledore
matrifactly then i'm dead too ah said
dumbledore smiling still more broadly
that is the question isn't it on the
whole dear boy i think not all right so
what makes dumbledore so sure then that
harry isn't dead i'm at most certain
dumbledore would be glad you asked for
as readers of the series will remember
dumbledore then goes into great detail
about how harry could have survived yet
another killing curse from voldemort but
if voldemort used to killing curse harry
started again and nobody died for me
this time how can i be alive i think you
know said dumbledore think back remember
what he did in his ignorance and his
greed and his cruelty
he took my blood said harry precisely
said dumbledore he took your blood and
rebuilt his living body with it your
blood in his veins harry lily's
protection inside both of you he
tethered you to life while he lives you
were the seventh horcrux harry the
horcrux he never meant to make he had
rendered his soul so unstable that it
broke apart when he committed those acts
of unspeakable evil the murder of your
parents the attempted killing of a child
but what escaped from that room was even
less than he knew he left more than his
body behind he left part of himself
latched to you the would-be victim who
had survived put all of that together
with the fact that harry's lifelong
lightning bolt scar has disappeared what
seems to have taken its place is a
nearby agonized creature who keeps
quietly moaning in the background a
creature that dumbledore insists is
beyond help and so it stands to reason
that perhaps the scar was the embodiment
of voldemort's seventh horcrux within
harry this would make sense as a horcrux
is a hidden fragment of a dark wizard
soul this would also explain the link
harry had with voldemort throughout the
books and how the scar would see with
pain when he would get a glimpse into
voldemort's mind so with the vanishing
of his trademark scar and the presence
of this stunted creature one can assume
that the creature now represents the
horcrux and its removal from harry's
body and soul
dumbledore all but confirms this theory
when he assures harry that the part of
voldemort's soul that was inside of him
was destroyed when voldemort did harry
with the killing curse this time around
saying your soul is whole and completely
your own harry okay so now we've laid
the groundwork for the where and the why
of harry's not quite death after being
hit with the killing curse he's in limbo
alive but not in the world of living due
to his link with voldemort who of course
still lives which brings us to the how
how did harry return from this alternate
plane of existence well in my opinion
we've already sort of answered this
question harry didn't die because
voldemort still lives with harry's blood
in his veins what was destroyed instead
was voldemort's horcrux and now harry's
soul is devoid of voldemort his soul is
whole and pure giving him the
opportunity to return to his life as
just harry all he has to do at this
point is choose to go back being that
his version of purgatory is at king's
cross station dumbledore suggests that
if harry chooses to move on into death
he would likely board a train and carry
on but of course harry chooses to return
to the world of the living in order to
try to finally defeat voldemort and help
save as many people as he can from
further death and destruction at this
point dumbledore begins to disappear
into a descending mist and you may begin
to wonder if any of this has actually
happened maybe harry just hit his head
really hard of course harry has this
exact same thought asking dumbledore one
final question before he completely
disappears harry wants to know i can
hardly blame him if any of this was real
or if it was only happening inside his
head to which dumbledore responds with
one of my all-time favorite lines of
course it is happening inside your head
harry but dwight nurse should that mean
that it is not real next thing we know
harry's back in the forbidden forest
lying face down once again this time
alive he has officially returned from
the dead and now you know how he did it
this of course brings us to the end of
this video if you enjoyed the content
i'd be grateful if you liked it and
subscribe to the channel as always happy
to hear your input on this and any other
harry potter theories just leave them in
the comments below and please feel free
to share any topics you'd like to see in
upcoming videos you guys always have
great ideas for more videos like this
one be sure to check out the harry
potter explained playlist it's got all
the info on harry potter you need plus
all the stuff you didn't know you needed
until next time remember it does not do
to dwell on dreams and forget to live
[Music]
you